Learner B4: هلو؟ هلو شباب هلو؟ هلا يا نارين.
Learner B3: هل هو من.
Learner B1: لو.
Learner B4: الأغوار. ويلكم متأخرة شوية.
Learner B3: الحمد لله ثانك يو. أنا كنت في بس كنت في جروب تاني يعني.
Learner B4: طيب إيه اللي خلاكي جروب.
Learner B3: هو أنا يعني كنت عاملة يعني حصل لغبطة كده فعملت التاست بتاعكو
Learner B3: فعشان كده المنتج. قال لي إن أنا عملت داسكاكو فهدوني الغروب بتاعكو.
Learner B4: أوكي طب حلو قوي طيب هي اخبار الدنيا معاكي في اللي فاتت.
Learner B3: حاسة والله الدنيا يعني في تشارينز بس حاسة الدنيا بالنسبة لي ده عاجبني أكتر بصراحة.
Learner B4: طيب حلو إيه يعني كنت شايفة الفروقات بين ده وبين.
Learner B3: هو التاني كانوا بيشتغلوا على سبينتس نفسه بتاعت سبرينز
Learner B3: هنا بيشتغلوا على حسب ما فهمت يعني.
Learner B4: أنا.
Learner B3: الأول بقى يعني كنت عارفة إن في جروب تاني وشغالين على.
Learner B4: أوكي فول حلوه ده حلو قوي.
Learner B3: إنت سعيدة مبارح إن إنت تعبانة.
Learner B4: الصراحة بس يعني فرانك تو سور باي.
Learner B3: طيب الحمد لله.
Learner B4: إن شاء الله الدنيا سباحة.
Learner B3: ان شاء الله تبي أحسن إن شاء الله.
Learner B4: إن شاء الله يا جميل تسلمي يا رب.
Learner B3: مع السلامة.
Learner B4: طيب أسألكم كده كان شفتاي أو كانت محطوطة
Learner B4: قولولي طيب الدنيا يعني قولي كده احنا فين في الدنيا دي.
Learner B3: هو إحنا مبارح عملنا شوية وهي بس أنا لما دخلت أصلا تانية كان فيها تقريبا كانوا ألريدي بادئين فيها واشتغلوا حبة حلوين. أنا بس زودت في الآخر كم سؤال يعني.
Learner B4: أوكي طيب
Learner B4: الحاجة بسر ما عنديش حاجات كتيرة بس أنا حسيت إن كلد باك فمش عارفة أشوف حاجة مختلفة. ولا شفت حاجة مش مزبوطة.
Learner B3: أنا مشكلتي الوحيدة حاسة إن هي طويلة أوي خايفة. إن هم يزاقوا في النص ويختاروا أي حاجة.
Learner B4: بصي إن أنا أشوفه في الأسئلة. لما قريتها لقيتها كلها بدور حوالين
Learner B4: أسئلة حولين تفيد باك انطباعاتك عن الفيد باك حسيت أثرت فيك بتفيد باك بس مش عن مش عن ذا غول مش على كل فول بروفيس فاهمين قصدي
Learner B4: بعدين إنتو شفتوا ده ولا لأ.
Learner B1: الأسئلة اللي هو في الأول معرفش يعني دي كان حاولت اخلي الاسئلة مش على بس ما فيش مشكلة يعني ممكن.
Learner B4: أنا حسيت إن الأسئلة عن الفيد باك بس يعني الأسئلة عكس كثير الأسئلة على الفيدباك بس.
Learner B1: إنه
Learner B1: يعني معرفش بس أنا لما عملتها ما كنتش هدفي الفيدباك بس كان هدفي اللي هو إيه المشاكل بوجه عام.
Learner B4: أوكي.
Learner B3: هو عامة. أنا حاسة إن دي حاجة الأفكار كلها وإحنا كده دلوقتي هنا نشوف إيه المهم.
Learner B1: الأول، أشوف.
Learner B4: أنا ماشي حابب التشيز كريم، ساعدني. أنا عملت شوت أسئلة كدا من عندي.
Learner B1: يعني أنا.
Learner B4: في.
Learner B1: كلكم انتم ممكن تعدلوا يعني عملوا كمان.
Learner B4: أوكي شكرا.
Learner B3: هي.
Learner B4: أسئلة.
Learner B3: معنا.
Learner B4: أنا بعتلها أشوفها هي فين.
Learner B1: يا زينب قفلة وياسر آفل.
Learner B4: مساء إسمي برايفات أشوف كده هو إيه وضعهم.
Learner B1: وانت بعتلهم.
Learner B4: أم.
Learner B1: فرنش.
Learner B4: طيب أنا حاولت أجيب الورك فلو قالها الباشمان بس أنا بصراحة ما لقيتش ما ردوش عليا خالص.
Learner B1: ما.
Learner B4: نعم.
Learner B1: فلو.
Learner B4: اللي أنا عملتلها شيرينغ.
Learner B1: لا مش مهندس محمد حاتم ما أنت طلبتي دور كيو معاك كده لينك فيغماك
Learner B1: ما كانش يقصد بيها البروتوتيبل بتاع التاسك ده هو فيها. أنا فهمت زي كده.
Learner B4: الفيديو تات في الجروب بتاع البرودكت صح.
Learner B4: ، أوكي أوكي بول طيب
Learner B4: خليني أوريكم الأسئلة، إني أنا شفتها مناسبة
Learner B4: أطول عليكم إن شاء الله عشان نلحق نخلص
Learner B4: بالله عليك طيب شو شوفي يا زهرة.
Learner B4: شو شعوبه.
Learner B1: أيوه أيوه ظهرت.
Learner B4: أنا ببساطة شديدة طيب حلو أوي طيب أنا شفت 1 أم بوردينغ إثنين ليرنينغ بتاعة التوست والقسم كوميونيكيشن وي
Learner B4: القسم الخاص بي السيركل والتورز اللي احنا بنستخدمه تمام.
Learner B1: أم.
Learner B4: في الورك فلو ده إحنا معانا الذكاء الاصطناعي، فأنا حبيت كل الأقسام دي هم مني سيفن سيفن سيكتورز أو سيفن سيكشن
Learner B4: إننا أسأل فيها أسئلة فايندا أوب وبالإندبسيشن
Learner B4: يعني عايز أقارن ما بين وقتين اللي عملناه في الأول كان في ناس عندها إعتراضات إن في ال إي آي هو اللي حيدينا في الباك
Learner B4: في ناس كانتش حبة في ناس بالنسبة كان عادي
Learner B4: فدي حابة أعرف التجربة الأولانية، وحابة أعرف كان بالنسبة لهم بلان واضحة ولا لأ مش شايفين معايا أسئلة صح.
Learner B3: أم.
Learner B4: طيب الحاجات اللي كنت حابب اشرحهالك في البداية وده ما حصلش
Learner B4: ولو انت اجيتنغ باك أون ذي أم بوردينج ميتينغ الحاجات. اللي انت حتحتاج تتغير.
Learner B3: أوكي.
Learner B4: القسم التاني قسم ليرنينغ باس بقى اللي احنا شغالين عليها ما لهم شوطا.
Learner B1: فكرة بعد ما الناس اشتركت فعلا في في الإنترنشب
Learner B1: طب قبل ما يشتركوا بقى قبل فكرة الدفع كانوا عارفين يعني اللي حصل فهماني.
Learner B4: إنت قصدك اللي هو قبل الميتينج صح؟
Learner B4: أوكي إنما دي ممكن ده كان ده السؤال ده ممكن يكفر النقطة دي.
Learner B1: أكتر حاجة كنت محتاج حد يشرحهالك في البداية إمم.
Learner B4: أنا مش عارفة.
Learner B1: ممكن.
Learner B4: طيب أنا لعبة في الدنيا المفروض إن أنا كنت أزبطه ماشي اوكي.
Learner B1: ولا يهمك.
Learner B4: من.
Learner B3: معلش يا ندى أنا بس حاسة إن هو سؤال حلو بس حاسة إن هو فعلا ممكن يكون دايريكت أكتر لو إحنا عايزين وهو ممكن ما يفهمش أو يجاوب قوي عايزين نسأل شرحلك أو عارف التفاصيل قبل ما تدخل ولا لأ.
Learner B4: ماشي خلاص إحنا ممكن نغير الاتصال مثلا نقول طيب ممكن نخليها مثلا المقارنة ما بين
Learner B4: اللي حاصل دلوقتي مين توقعاته قبل ما اشترك الإختلافات أو بتاعته.
Learner B3: أو ممكن نقول مثلا ده سؤال حلو ممكن في الآخر بس إحنا ممكن نقول هل إنت كنت على علم بكل التفاصيل. ويعني الإجراء الجينش بيمشي ازاي قبل ما تدخل
Learner B3: فاهمة قصدي.
Learner B4: كده.
Learner B3: بكل تغطي تدريب.
Learner B1: تمام
Learner B1: فهمت.
Learner B4: برأيك الله يخليك الأول.
Learner B1: الرقم.
Learner B4: كويس مافيهاش فلوس.
Learner B1: واضحة.
Learner B4: افضح كده.
Learner B1: بص.
Learner B4: أشيلها خالص. أنا.
Learner B1: هو ممكن يكون المشكلة إمم.
Learner B4: حاولت أعمل ده بس ما ما ظبطتش برضه.
Learner B1: خلص ممكن يكون اوضح شوي.
Learner B4: أوكي ماشي
Learner B4: طيب أنا يعني أنا بشارككم ان انا فكرت فيهم التقسيمة مش شرط تبقى صحه خالص يعني شوف ازاي طيب القسم الثاني.
Learner B3: 70.
Learner B4: ليرنينغ قولي قول.
Learner B3: لا كنت بقلك حاجة إحنا لو قسمناها فعلا كده حبة بعدين تأكدنا ان هو كل حاجة متماشية عالفورم حيبقى أحسن.
Learner B4: يعني هي تبقى ماشية بنفس التقسيمة تقصدي.
Learner B3: نقسمها تقسيمات كده أوضح.
Learner B4: تمام
Learner B4: طيب حلو ليرنينغ بروسيس هنا شوية أنا حامشي معاهم في حدة التصكي بالنسباله كانت واضحة
Learner B4: بتبدأ فيها ازاي لما بتجيلك بالنسبة لك واضحة؟ طيب لو مش فاهم التثقي اللي بيساعدك تفهم التثقيف. هل بتكلم المنتور هتشوف زمايلك هل بتسأل هل بتبص على أي موجودة مثلا في الدنيا بتمشي معاك ازاي ولو انت
Learner B4: بالنسبالك الطقس مش واضحه ليه بتختار أي تول من دي
Learner B4: مش معنى دي بالنسبة لك هي اللي بتسهلك الوقت.
Learner B1: أنا عايز اعرف هو استفاد من سارة وأحمد استفاد منهم. اتعلم منهم حاجة يعني من ناحية.
Learner B4: بالظبط بالزبط هم ساعدوك في اي حاجة لها علاقة بالتسكرة.
Learner B1: لا.
Learner B4: لو في ما راح تمتص قولي.
Learner B1: الشرجب تي، والإي غير أحمد غير أحمد منصور ومين تاني وصارة.
Learner B4: طيب خلينا نقول ونحدده.
Learner B4: انا كان اقصد به محمد منصور قصارى ليمون أحمر.
Learner B1: كان كان في معضلة مبارح إن إحنا مش عايز أقول إنهم إي
Learner B1: عشان لو في ناس متعرفش هما
Learner B1: أو عايز أشوف إيه تفكير الناس يعني.
Learner B4: أوكي ماشي
Learner B4: نخلي دول جزء من المتر ونخليهم منفصلين عن المنكر.
Learner B4: هل يمكن.
Learner B1: أنا أنا برضه أنا عايز أعرف الفرق بين المنتور وما بين أحمد يوسف مش مهندس أحمد يوسف أو مش مهندس أحمد مرزوق.
Learner B4: وكذلك أحمد يوسف، لكن احمد منصور وساره دول مختلفين.
Learner B1: عشان كدا.
Learner B4: فخلينا نسميهم باساميهم احسن.
Learner B1: من.
Learner B4: أني فيهم بالنسبة له بيسعدوا أكثر ليه
Learner B4: ولو في مرة تذكر كنش مطلوب
Learner B4: يحكي لي بالضبط ما الذي حصل.
Learner B3: أنا عندي بس حاجة على نوعية السؤال دي حاسه ان احنا مفروض اوي الأسئلة اللي بنسألها تبقى أوبن كده عشان ممكن كل 1 يجاوب ب فورم مختلف واحنا في أسئلة معينة عايزين نقيس. كم عدد 1 شايف كدا
Learner B3: فأنا حاسة النوعية دي مثلا نقول إنت إيه اللي بيعطلك في شايف. إنها مش واضحة. كفاية هل شايف مثلا إن هو في مكان مختلف فده سبب لخبطة يعني عايزين يعني نجمع أرقام في الآخر فاهمة.
Learner B4: طيب إيه رأيك لو أنا خليني أسأل حاجة زي دي
Learner B4: منك مش واضح فيبقى في نعم او لا الله.
Learner B3: بصي هو إحنا خلينا في بتاعك إن إحنا نجمع الأفكار بتاعتنا أصلا في الفورم فيها تقريبا كل الأسئلة الممكنة تخطر على بالي يعني هو ما شاء الله مليانة أسئلة كثير قوي.
Learner B4: أي.
Learner B1: مكررة وفي أسئلة ممكن يعني حنشيل أسئلة.
Learner B3: جدا شغل عظيم يعني بس إحنا فعلا ممكن نضبط الشغل يعني بس.
Learner B4: طيب يا طب نرجع للشيز بتاعتكوا أو الملف اللي في الأول وبص عليه طيب خلينا نكمل.
Learner B1: حاجة إنت كملي؟ وهنا.
Learner B4: دي حنخليها نعم، ولو كان مش مطهو لو نعم، يحكينا إلحق تمام الكسكاست الخاص كل منه
Learner B4: وقت قد في حاجة عطلته في الحل وهل في داتا الجزء بتاعك؟ عادل؟ هل ده تأثرت عليها؟ ولا ما تأثرتش
Learner B4: طيب الجزء الأخير أو الجزء الرابع الخاص بالفيد داك الفيد باك وصله بعد
Learner B4: فهم سبب التقييم دا أو سبب الأجول أو الرفض
Learner B4: وإيه اللي خلاه اللي ساعدوا الخلاية حسنه يعني هل الفيد باك ساعده اللي بعديها ولا لأ
Learner B4: ولو حبيت تسأل أو تفهم إن فيدات اللي جالك عشان إنت عندك 1 اللي انت عايز تحسنه
Learner B4: حبيب تفهم منو اكتر ازاي حسنه هل وصلك إجابة منه؟ ولا ما وصلك.
Learner B1: وصلت في البكر كان
Learner B1: طب أنا برضه كانت فكرة التفككوت تعدد المنصات أثرت عليك بإيه
Learner B1: يعني فاكر المشكلة الأولانية خالص لما قعدنا يومين فاكرين إن الدقيق هو اللي بعتلي بعث لكل 1 فينا اللي هو أحمد منصور بعد كل 1 فينا مختلف
Learner B1: بعد كده لما دخلنا؟ مع
Learner B1: لما حد دخل معانا قال لنا؟ لا غير تيبل ده قصر معاه فحاجة.
Learner B4: الإيميل.
Learner B1: ما.
Learner B4: لأ و.
Learner B1: فرنش
Learner B1: قوم.
Learner B4: والله مش عارف.
Learner B1: ان ان النت وحش كده تمام الو.
Learner B4: يعني يقول كده.
Learner B1: الو.
Learner B4: ألو السلام عليكم.
Learner B1: الهند.
Learner B1: أوكي كده تمام مع إني كويس كده.
Learner B3: قدر.
Learner B1: لك
Learner B1: كنت بقولك على فكرة اللي هو تعدد المنصات اللي هو زي فكرة إيه ارتي بول والإي آي لما بعت لنا أول يومين خالص إحنا سحلنا مش فاهمين كل 1 فينا يبعتله طاقته مختلفة.
Learner B1: تمام وفي الآخر. حدد دخل قال لنا إن إن التذكرة أصلا على.
Learner B4: لا موجودة حاليا.
Learner B1: السؤال ده حيغطي يعني حتة.
Learner B4: بعدين خلال بصي في الكوميونيكيشن.
Learner B1: مش.
Learner B4: ما سمعنا هنا.
Learner B1: سمن.
Learner B4: طيب عندك صياغة معينة حابب ان احنا نكتبها.
Learner B1: والله نحنا ما رحنا قرن.
Learner B4: بص أنا حسيب دي زي ما هي كده يعني حشارتكم اللي موجود هنا.
Learner B1: المنصات. أثر عليك ثانية واحدة بسألك في أموت.
Learner B4: طبعا.
Learner B3: صرنا تقريبا توحش
Learner B3: أنا بقى عندي سؤال مختلف.
Learner B4: أنا مش سامعكم.
Learner B1: كنت بقولك السؤال فين شيت تمام.
Learner B4: ماشي كملت عليك كذاب.
Learner B1: كان.
Learner B4: ماشي.
Learner B1: أم طيب ده الحيوان عندي بيقطع.
Learner B4: لا لا ولا يهمك
Learner B4: طيب القسم القسم الثاني ده إحنا ممكن نحطه يعني أنا كنت حاطه بشكل أوبشنال لو إحنا عندنا ملاحظات أصلا على استخدام
Learner B4: أو استخدامه، شيكل
Learner B4: أكتر حاجة عجبتهم لو في حاجة ديقتهم لو في خطوة بحيث إن أنا دي بتضيعلي وقتي إني أروح أبص على مثلا وأرجع ثاني أبص على سيركل وأرتب توتة
Learner B4: ولو في خاصية فيتشر موجودة أنا محتاجة تكون في السيركل أو في بحيث إنها تنجلي الامور طيب
Learner B4: هنا السؤال هل احنا اضطرينا نلجأ لشريط جيوبتي والإيه عشان ولا لأ
Learner B4: ولو استخدمتو في تحديدا.
Learner B3: أنا بجد حاسة إن هو ممكن الناس أصلا تجاوب السؤال ده غلط أو ما تحبش تجاوب عليه.
Learner B4: علشان خاطر ما يبانش إن هم مثلا في أفيوز أو في حاجة.
Learner B3: أو مع أن هذه يعني المفروض يستخدم.
Learner B4: ممكن نخلي ده أوبشنال.
Learner B3: ممكن.
Learner B4: إختياري بالنسبة لهم
Learner B4: خالينا مدام مثلا ذاهبة يسرنو السؤال ده مظبوط
Learner B4: يا ربي طيب الحاجة اللي عايزين نعرفها هي أكثر شيء خلوه متحمس يكمل التدريب اللي خلاه يكمل لحد دلوقتي
Learner B4: الحاجات التي خلتهم ممكن يكونوا لا، انا لن اكمل هذه ليست مناسبة
Learner B4: لو هو شخص مسؤول ثالث حاجات هيوز يغيرها؟
Learner B4: وهل هو هيعمل كومنديشنر للتدريب بتاع فرنك ولا مش هيعمل ولو ليه ولو لاء ليه
Learner B4: ولو عندهم أي ريكوميندي
Learner B4: في أسئلة تانية لو المترو مش موجود لمدة أسبوع زي ما حصل معانا في 3 ايام انت هتعمل
Learner B4: الحاجات اللي شايفها بالضيعة وقتك في التدريب حاجات ملهاش لازمة الحاجات اللي في التوصيات شايفها بتتكرر
Learner B4: امتى آخر مرة حسيت انك مش عارف اصلا انت ضايع ومش فاهم انت فين ومش فاهم. انت الغرض من التدريب وخلاص الدنيا كده مظلمة معاك
Learner B4: والحاجات اللي لو موجودة ده تكملة للسؤال اللي فوق حتشوف. إنها حتوصل عليك وقت كبير وخليك تستفيد أكثر من كل
Learner B4: ولو في مرة. هل إنت أجلت طاسة قبل كده ولا لأ ده أجابته يسر نوم ولو اجلتها، السبب
Learner B4: من فضلك. نعم، أوه، اكتر حاجة خدت منك
Learner B4: وقت في قرارات مثلا، مش موجودة فأنا إضطريت أدور كتير قلت في الآخر أعمل أي حاجة
Learner B4: ده من ضمن الحاجات لو هتوصف التدريب ده اختار 3 كلمات
Learner B4: توصف بيها التدريب ولو انا هديك تقييم لكل مرحلة من المراحل نحن ذكرناها فوق من 10 حتدي تقييم كم من 10.
Learner B3: أم
Learner B3: ومنظم بس وبرضه يعتبر حاطط كل الأسئلة دي بقى بالتفصيل يعني فإحنا ممكن برضه نشكل فوام كده ونشوف نشيل.
Learner B1: من.
Learner B4: فرنش.
Learner B1: مرحبا ، فرنك.
Learner B3: بس هو السؤال هنا بقى إحنا لو بعتنا على طول ولا هيقول مثلا هيدي باك أو كومنت أو ممكن الموضوع يتأخر
Learner B3: هو انتو معايا.
Learner B4: أنا معاكي أنا سامعاكي.
Learner B3: لو بعتنا للمانتر حيقولنا تمام ولا تفتكر ممكن يبقى فيدباك الأول وكده فموضوع يتأخر.
Learner B3: ادخل.
Learner B4: وإحنا حنبعت في.
Learner B3: أوكي.
Learner B4: يعني تقدر
Learner B4: إنت خريجة مريغا ولا يعني يجيني كده عرفتينا عليكي.
Learner B3: درست كومبيوتر ساينس سنتي.
Learner B4: البيوت الفرنس حلو قوي ولا لسه طالبة.
Learner B3: لا، لا تخرجت انت درستي والدنيا إيه برضه.
Learner B4: أنا خريجة تجارة إنجلش كنت بدرس بيزنس وشغالة في السفن.
Learner B3: إذا في البرنامج ولا.
Learner B4: لا، لا، فروم بيزنس.
Learner B3: طب حلو شكلك ما شاء الله عندك خبرة فا
Learner B3: إيه اللي خلاكي تعرفي تروحي ل برودكت.
Learner B4: حقولك أنا شغلي
Learner B4: دوري إيه بالزبط أنا دوري بعد ما السيلز بيبيعوا البرودكت أنا بعمل ترينغ لل ك لا على
Learner B4: سواء كان كلاود او سواء سي آر اي حاجة من دي.
Learner B3: أم.
Learner B4: ايتسكاين ده فيها حتت بس من حتة إننا بيتشرز اللي هم ازايكتس وأحاول أخلي فيتشرز بتاعتنا سرف اللي هم محتاجينه
Learner B4: فده بيخليني آخذ من كاستمر لأ أنا قصي فيتشر دي لأن دي مش مناسبة لأن مختلفة عن أوفيشال ون وحاجات زي كده فأنا بتعلم معبس وال إنجينيرج وكل بروسي.
Learner B3: أم.
Learner B4: فحسيت إن برودكت مانجمنت في الحتة دي سواء كشغلي أنا الحالي، أو حتى لو أنا عايزة أعمل كريشن.
Learner B3: مفيدة بالنسبة لك.
Learner B4: صوفر يس إن أنا بالنسبة لي محتاجة افهم
Learner B4: هاو ذي برودكت ذي مانجر ثينج
Learner B4: والماين سيت بتاعتهم وأنا مش عندي خالص يعني أنا عاجبني جدا الإنزبي اللي عاملينو يعني مثلا عظيم تدرس لوحدي
Learner B4: والبيت ناصر القنابل.
Learner B3: اللي بعتينو ده صح.
Learner B4: أولوياتهم.
Learner B3: أم أنا ما دام حاسة الفيد باك بس الهيومن مش يعني الفيدباك أحمد تقريبا مفيد قوي.
Learner B4: تحفة ده تحفة فيدباغ بتاع ال إي آي
Learner B4: أنا عايزة أقولك أول فاصل معاه لحد ما اداني سكور.
Learner B4: أحسنت انا ما غيرتش انا فصلت معي.
Learner B3: بصراحة يعني بيبقى أكتر حاجة همي هيومان فيدباك يعني أنا فعلا فارق معي التفكير أكتر من سكوير هو مهم كل حاجة بس أنا ده هدفي الأول يعني.
Learner B4: بالضبط هو ده اللي بيفرق، فأنا بالنسبة لي
Learner B4: احمد مرزوده هي كان مهم يعني انا بستنى ال افهمه.
Learner B3: أم مستوى دائما يعني بيبقى نفس الفكرة لو إحنا لازم ندق أكتر نعرف الدنيا ماشية إزاي
Learner B3: عايزة أبقى أشير معاكم برضه شوية أسئلة كدا عايزة أبعتها وبرضه نقعد نعملها بس بعد ما نخلص الفورم يعني إن شاء الله
Learner B3: عادل.
Learner B4: قوليلي إيه.
Learner B3: بصي هو من فيدباك بتاعو آخر مرة هو إنتو هم كانوا حكولي مبارح إنه إنتو عملتوا مختلف. أنا حاسة تقريبا التاسسك ده يعني أنا برضو عملت حاجة مختلفة وإنتو تبعتلكوا حاجة مختلفة،
Learner B3: فهو الفي باك اللي هو دهوني إن إحنا محتاجين نسأل يعني أوكي بيشتكوا من حاجة بس إحنا محتاجين برضه نعرف ليه سبرينس ماشية الدنيا كده
Learner B3: يعني مثلا هم بيبعتوا مثلا تو فيرجينس قبل ما أدي مثلا على طول بناء على سبينس أصلا. حسيت ميك سينس
Learner B3: إن أنا كتبت بقى شوية أسئلة مش كتير يعني فعايزة أزود نفهم الستوري يبقى من سبينس.
Learner B4: بتفقئ معاكي.
Learner B3: بصي انت لو بتتكلميها ومعمول مين إنت.
Learner B1: هو متر و20 حاجة.
Learner B3: إل إي.
Learner B1: جبن متوحش.
Learner B3: أم.
Learner B4: فمعاكي معاكي جدا يا ريت.
Learner B3: كده أنا سامعاكي.
Learner B4: في قدامك.
Learner B3: متفقة معايا أنا حسيت الفيدباك فعلا اللي هو قالوا حسب برضه ميك سينس الصراحة
Learner B3: غير طريقة بتاعي، شوية فبس نظبط بقى الأسئلة سوا كده بعد ما نخلص يعني إن شاء الله.
Learner B4: إن شاء الله.
Learner B1: ممكن تحل ممكن تدخلي على لما اضطريت.
Learner B4: أبتدي. أنا.
Learner B1: مشيت ل.
Learner B4: أوكي ميرسي أوكي
Learner B4: أنا محتاجة أكشن ما تلقنا.
Learner B1: ما عندي ابني
Learner B1: تمام
Learner B1: خالتي.
Learner B4: تمام خلطة برافو.
Learner B1: دي كل الأسئلة وكدا وفي يا فيلم لا يفوق كده
Learner B1: بالزبط.
Learner B4: عظيم جدا ما كانش عندي على.
Learner B1: جمعت الأسئلة عشان محدش يطلب تشيلي وفي الآخر بتاعتك هنا يعني تزودي وبحطي الأسئلة بتاعتك هنا
Learner B1: وانا كلكم اللي حابب يضيف علشان إيه فين.
Learner B3: فمش حاسين إن إحنا نشوف من الفورم يعني دي تبقى أوضح.
Learner B1: يعني تلغبطت خلينا.
Learner B4: وصل حصة يعني محتاجين يعني خالص الموضوع اليوم صح؟
Learner B4: حتى لو أنا بعت حاجة بدائية أو شوية كوسيشنز جزء من الأسئلة بحيث احنا النهاردة الثلاث.
Learner B1: بصي أنا ما عنديش يعني أنا ما عنديش مشكلة يعني أنا اللي عامل فورم أهم حاجة يعني نتفق على الأسئلة اعتبروا إن الفورم اللي عملتها دي كإنها ما تعملتش عادي خالص عايزين يفتحوها تمام برضه ما فيش مشكلة أهم حاجة بس إن إحنا نتفق على الأسلحة.
Learner B3: طيب خلاص خلينا السؤال اللي تمام نعمل عليه هايلايت بالأخضر.
Learner B1: لا السؤال الغلط يعني أو.
Learner B3: طيب خلينا نمشي على سؤال سؤال ونشوف تمام ولا لأ.
Learner B1: آمين.
Learner B4: تمام.
Learner B1: كلكم أكو الشدة.
Learner B3: أنا بس عندي حاجة في أول سؤال هو هل لو الناس بتكتب فيدباك في ناس ممكن ما تحبش تكتب إسمها؟
Learner B1: هو هدف اصلا هدف الفيد باك ان انا اعرفهم وأعمل معاهم.
Learner B3: إمم.
Learner B4: نلحق ده كله الأسبوع ده يعني.
Learner B3: لا ده للدم مودي أكيد أصدق صح.
Learner B1: حتى لو يعني يبقى معانا في أي وقت إنت بس ممكن تشيلي رقم الموبايل عشان أنا مش مقتنعة بيها عادي.
Learner B3: أو.
Learner B4: والله أنا صراحة.
Learner B1: يعني أم.
Learner B3: طب حتى يعني مثلا ممكن يقرأ بصوت عالي أو نمشي على 1 1 بس.
Learner B4: طيب ماشي هو التراك طبعا بعد ذلك مستوى الخبره اول مره معرفه بسيطه متوسطه خبرة عملية
Learner B4: تقييم التجربة. فروم ون تو كان
Learner B4: أول ما دخلت التدريب كان إيه إحساسك فاهم الدنيا ولا احتجت وقت شوية ولا كنت تايه لحد دلوقتي في حاجات مش واضحة
Learner B4: من ده أول حاجة عملتها بعد إستلام أول قصف بدأت تشتغل في الجهاز كده
Learner B4: خدتوا وقت قد عشان تبدأ تنفذ أول طفل
Learner B4: إيه أكتر حاجة أخلتك قبل ما تبتدي وانت شغال كنت بترجع لتعليمات قد ولا مرة
Learner B4: أول مرة السؤال ده
Learner B4: يعني وانت شغال كنت ترجع لسان.
Learner B1: مثلا كنت بتفتح الإي آي وتشوف الحاجة أدي تمام.
Learner B4: ليها تتفركي.
Learner B1: لو هو فاهم التعليمات أو فاهم لو التذكر بالنسباله واضحة من أول مرة
Learner B1: اول مرة اقراها يبقى كده خلاص التاسكات واضحة ومش محتاج يقراها خمسمية مرة عشان يتأكد لو كل شوية بفتح.
Learner B3: سراح.
Learner B1: أوكي.
Learner B4: طب ما هي دي نفس أول حاجة عملت استلام أول بدأت أشتغل مباشر ألقيت تعليمات أكثر من مرة.
Learner B1: بالضبط في أسئلة مكررة وأنا.
Learner B4: سلامة.
Learner B1: في فيدباك اي معترف بكده.
Learner B3: أنا برضه عايزين أزود سؤال هي أنت بتاخد منك وقت قد إيه وإنت مزود السؤال ده.
Learner B1: موجود وحنعدله.
Learner B4: ، موجود، سواء موجود هنا أو موجود حتى في موجود فمش خليه.
Learner B3: بس سؤال على إستغرقت وقت أد إيه قبل ما نتنافس أول ممكن يعني ممكن يبقى حد مشغول أو كده فممكن ما يفهموش إن هو بسبب اللخبطة، فأنا حاسس بصراحة إن هو مالوش لازمة.
Learner B1: على قبل ما تنفذ الدوس.
Learner B4: ممكن عشان تفهم التاسك مثلا تفهم لتحت أكتر.
Learner B3: يعني ممكن
Learner B3: بس أنا حاسة إن في أسئلة. ألريدي بتجوبة عن السؤال ده بس ممكن لو عايزينه يبقى الكيس نعدلهم ممكن.
Learner B4: ماشي ممكن خليها كده مؤقتا لحد ما لو لقينا حاجة ننزل.
Learner B3: هو بس الفورم طويل أوي، فإحنا بجد محتاجين إن إحنا نقلل على قد ما نقدر.
Learner B4: يعني لما كنت أول حاجة بتعملها أعتقد سيكون والله.
Learner B1: من جهة.
Learner B3: حسب.
Learner B1: شو هيدا مارس.
Learner B3: بس حاسة إن وي لايف طبيعي الواحد يوقف كل شوية ويعني هتبقى زي لايف حاسه برضه ملهاش لزمة قوي
Learner B3: ندى أنا بس حساكي يعني بتطلعي وبتنزلي كده.
Learner B1: نشوف الأسئلة كلها.
Learner B4: أه.
Learner B3: أوكي.
Learner B4: أنا شايفة اللي انت مغطي كل حاجة في أسئلتك يعني.
Learner B1: ماشي ممكن بس نتأكد إن هو
Learner B1: ما فيش الأسئلة اللي هتدي نفس الكيد باك عشان هي أسئلة كتيرة جدا تمام
Learner B1: وإيه تاني ولو في حد حابب يضيف يعني في أسئلة بالضبط كمية.
Learner B3: وثانيا، أنت مش جايب ده من الفرن.
Learner B1: هي دي هي هي حاجة دي هي.
Learner B3: هذا.
Learner B1: كجدول وقلنا نلم الحاجة في حاجة وحدة بس عشان يبقى سهل علينا بدل ما.
Learner B3: أصل أنا زودت كم سؤال بس أنت مش عارفة حاططهم في أنيق مع أي حد.
Learner B1: طيب ثانية وحدة كنت في الفور.
Learner B3: أنا بس مقسمهم بالأسامي بس أنا مش فارقة عادي تحط مع أي حد.
Learner B1: إمم.
Learner B4: أنا وصيت على أسئلة وين وأسئلة زينب وحتى أسئلتي آي بلي فاحنا.
Learner B1: طيب.
Learner B3: تحبن بالصال.
Learner B1: في الآخر.
Learner B3: لا حطتهم في النص كده يعني تابعة.
Learner B1: أم وهات لي معلش. أنا مش موجودين من ضمن الأسئلة أنا ما حطلهمش.
Learner B3: معلش
Learner B3: أنا حاسة ممكن نعدي كدا على الفورم برضه ولو عشان هي فعلا معظمها تمام لو تمام بجد نشيل الفورم على طول
Learner B3: أنا أعمل شير ممكن تخليني أعمل شير طيب.
Learner B1: عادي. افتح معك يا عيني حنفتح.
Learner B3: هو مش مخليني. أعمل شيء.
Learner B1: مش حنخليكي بس.
Learner B3: أم.
Learner B1: ندم ممكن تقتلوا الشيران عشان مريم تعمل شير.
Learner B4: أكيد يلا.
Learner B1: أم.
Learner B3: رمضان شيلو ده تمام ده تمام
Learner B3: هو مش حاسس إن إحنا ممكن نخليها من 5.
Learner B1: 5 فتيات.
Learner B3: بس أوكي تدقيق مكنس
Learner B3: أمي عشان زودت السؤال ده إزاي تعاملت مع لغة الإيجند
Learner B3: اللغة صعبة بشكل عام اللغة عادية لكن المصطلحات التقنية كانت صعبة اللغة من المصطلحات التقنية صعبين اللغة صعبة لكن المصطلحات التقنية كانت مناسبة
Learner B3: لو واجهت مشكلة في وضوح التاسك ده عشان لغة التاسسك صعبة ريكويرمنت مش واضحة كفاية ريكومنت واضحة لكن ممكن يبقى في شرح أكتر الريكوريمنتس واضحة وصيغة. أو شكل التسليم مش واضحة
Learner B3: هل تحب تختار المشروع.
Learner B4: ممكن أقولكم على سماعيل.
Learner B3: ، أوي.
Learner B1: توت قطة.
Learner B3: وزودوا دول برضه هل تحبي تختار المشروع اللي تشتغل عليه بنفسك؟ أوكي
Learner B3: وهل الأفضل تشوف كاملة وشاملة بكل من البداية اللي هو الأربع أسابيع كل أسبوع هتعمل في إيه وكده
Learner B3: أود الإختيارات تاني مش فاكرة بصراحة لو حطيت حاجة تانية ولا لأ.
Learner B4: ممكن تبعتلي بس اللينك بتاع الفورمي.
Learner B1: كنا بعتهالك من دقيقة عليها ثانية. وحدة.
Learner B3: في سؤال برضه حطيتو حجم التاسسك بالنسبالك عشان كدا طويل طويل جدا ومجهد ولا طويل لحد ما مناسب ولا قصير
Learner B3: بس.
Learner B4: عظيم جدا. جدا.
Learner B4: طيب أنا عايز بس ، قول.
Learner B3: كنت أقول بس أنا شايفة إن إحنا الفورم ألريدي جاهزة أوكي إحنا بس نشيل منها الموبايل وكده ونبعتها.
Learner B1: وصل.
Learner B3: بعتها لبنتي.
Learner B4: أنا بتفق معك جدا. حبص سريعا لو تسمحولي هعملها بس كان سريع جدا.
Learner B3: في الم ممكن أوقف شي واعملي شي لو عايز.
Learner B4: أنا بعمل سكان أسرع مما تتخيلي.
Learner B1: يعني أنا مثلا حتة الروب بتاعت رقم الموبايل دي شلتها تمام.
Learner B4: الإيه.
Learner B1: اللي هو رقم الموبايل.
Learner B4: أم.
Learner B1: شلتها سؤالي لإنتو عدلتوه مثلا نخلي بدل 10 نخلي 5
Learner B1: تمام شوفي الأسئلة المطلوبة فين
Learner B1: تأكدي من حديد اللفة ما بين اي واحمد وأحمد وصارة اللي هم الاي آي بتاع ال.
Learner B4: إمم.
Learner B1: مش يعني كنت بتعملي سكاني تأكدي من.
Learner B4: تعمل تي شيرت دلوقتي، صح؟
Learner B3: بس.
Learner B1: تلاقيهم افتحي النيل خشي عليهم على النيل مفتوح.
Learner B4: تبعت لينك في الشتات.
Learner B1: هم.
Learner B4: فرنس.
Learner B1: إمم.
Learner B4: يا روان إنت سامعنا طب معنا بتكتب لنا أي حاجة
Learner B4: لو عندك برضه أي تعليق أي
Learner B4: زي الفل زي الفل لو عندك أي ملاحظات تكتبيها برضه على طول
Learner B4: تسلمي يا رب
Learner B4: أنا عايز اللي يبعت لينك في حاجة برضه عايز أقلكم عليها ممكن تفيدكم يعني عموما بحب أعملها.
Learner B3: قوليلي أه قولي.
Learner B4: ميرسي.
Learner B1: ما.
Learner B4: في حاجة عندي اسمها سباكت أو يوزر
Learner B4: ليه لما جيت قسمت السكشنز بتاعتي
Learner B4: اللي هم الإيه سكشنز حبيت إن أنا كل سيكشن من دول
Learner B4: أنا عايزة أوصل منه لإيه يعني انا ليه بسأل السؤال ده سيكشن ده أنا عايز أوصل منه للإجابة على السؤال ده هتديني
Learner B4: انديكاتر أو إينسايد خاصة بإيه.
Learner B4: فمثلا هنا عندي هنا دي اسمها يوزرز يوزر غول بتاعي من السؤال ده مثلا
Learner B4: إن أنا يكون عندي وورك فلو هل هي متفقة مع الورك فلول اللي بعتوها ولا أنا عامل وورك فلو أنا في خيالي والواقع مختلف فأنا هنا عندي مثلا
Learner B4: في ال أشوف ماسينج فروميشنال فين
Learner B4: طيب هنا مثلا الخاص بالصوص أنا عايشة في أنهي حتة والميزة كل
Learner B4: انترنت عندي هو كان حصله أن ماتشينج كان إيه وهكذا تباع
Learner B4: مثلا ال ساسك أو الفيل دا كان واضح ولا لأ فأنا مثلا بسأل أسئلة عشان أوصل إجابة للسؤال ده
Learner B4: فأنا أقدر من خلالها إن أنا عندي قدام الورك، فلو تبقى جاهزة يبان عارف إن ده مسك في الحتة دي من الورك فلو وأنا عندي مثل فيدباك والله فيدباك بالنسباليز الفيد باك مكانش كفاية الفيد باك مثلا مكنش واضح
Learner B4: عندي الحتة بتاعت احمد وصاره لا والله فيدباك كويس
Learner B4: وهكذا فانا حعرف في كل مكان اللي نقص في كل سايكل مثلا حبيت ان انا أقولكم ده كان.
Learner B3: لا ابدا.
Learner B4: في.
Learner B3: فكرة حلوة قوي بصراحة هي التوكيمنت إسمو ويثير شكيت صح الفكرة يعني.
Learner B4: أو.
Learner B3: في.
Learner B4: لا.
Learner B3: ثانك يو بتحكي عنها ثانك يو فور شيرينج يعني.
Learner B4: زين كورس مش أنا أصلي كده.
Learner B1: معاكي ولا في مشكلة برضه.
Learner B4: لأ هيك سحر فتح معي ينزل كده صح
Learner B4: الله الله لا لا لا لا
Learner B4: الرئيس كل حاجة
Learner B4: على حسب سألتك كم مرة تمنيت يكون في شخص حيجي دا
Learner B4: كأننا بعمل ريغر للشخص أو حيجاوب على السؤال ده إن هو شخص.
Learner B3: بس مش أنا أنا.
Learner B4: بوجهه ناحية الإجابة دي.
Learner B1: عايز طريق جبل يمكن عايزاه تختارينه.
Learner B3: أنا ما تنحس بأي أسئلة إحنا عاملينو إلى فهم إحنا منسهل الأوياء وبنزقه.
Learner B4: منين بنوجهوا.
Learner B3: بس أنا مثلا الأسئلة في أسئلة
Learner B3: لا بس هي فكرة مش كده برضه هي فكرة إن هو في أسئلة كتيرة مبنية أصلا على شكاوي هم قالوها.
Learner B3: فهما حاجة ألريدي هم قالوا قبل كده فإحنا عشان لما نعرضها على سبينس نقول باهي
Learner B4: أنا مش سامعيني.
Learner B3: والنت مش مش حلو.
Learner B4: طيب أنت تسمعيني كده طيب ولا لسه مش لذيذ.
Learner B1: كده تمام.
Learner B4: طيب أنا أنا بس كان عندي حتت لو تمنيت إن في شخص حقيقي فده ممكن يكون.
Learner B1: في.
Learner B4: حبيبي.
Learner B1: أمين شي عشان نشوفك.
Learner B4: أهاه يا كريم ترمين.
Learner B1: ويش اللي بتحمل.
Learner B1: لما بيه.
Learner B4: ثانية واحدة يقول لك رحيم بحاول نجيبهم
Learner B4: لا، أنا مش عم بعمل كده
Learner B4: وهو شايفين دي.
Learner B1: فرنش.
Learner B4: كأنك بتقله إن إنت معاك شخص حقيقي
Learner B4: فاهم قصدي يعني حاسة السؤال ده أنا بودي الإجابة.
Learner B1: طب بس حقولك على حاجة ماشي أنا متفق معاكي تمام بس إحنا فعلا ساعات كنا محتاجين
Learner B1: مهندس أحمد يوسف أو أحمد أحمد مرزوق كان يرد علينا تمام.
Learner B4: يبقى ممكن نسأله بطريقة تانية بقى.
Learner B1: أيوة بالظبط نسأله بطريقة ثانية بقى
Learner B4: مثلا قول خلينا خلينا نسمي امتى كنت محتاج حد من المينتونز يكون معاك أول بأول.
Learner B1: وده مش هيبقى حاجة غلط مش معي اول بأول.
Learner B4: ما أظنش على أد ما السؤال ده معناه صحية أصلا بيتواصل معاها.
Learner B1: طيب ماشي اتكل على الله.
Learner B3: بس أنا ممكن.
Learner B4: أو مثلا.
Learner B3: إنتو.
Learner B4: أوض.
Learner B3: إمتى لأ كنت أقول بس إيمتى وجود المنتر مناسب ليك
Learner B3: لأنه هو مش طبيعي برضه هو يبقى موجود كل ثانية. فهذه الفكرة.
Learner B4: طيب ممكن نخلي دي مثلا خاصة بتواصل إيه
Learner B4: طريقة التواصل مع المنتسبالك سهلة ولا محتاجة تتحسن.
Learner B3: إمم الأوساط.
Learner B4: تمام لو لاء لو لاء إديني تفاصيل.
Learner B3: إمم أنا حاسة إن إحنا كإننا بجد شغال.
Learner B4: يروح.
Learner B3: مش مش إنت.
Learner B4: طيب وأنا قلته.
Learner B1: يا.
Learner B4: مشكلة.
Learner B1: أم.
Learner B4: ميش 1,000 طريقي توفوا.
Learner B4: نعم، حلو كينة.
Learner B4: أهلا
Learner B4: تمام أيوة عشان انا عارفه الناس لأ يعني صعبة.
Learner B3: بصي خليها كانت سهلة.
Learner B4: ماشي عشان نوفر على إيه علينا كانت سهلة وين كان تصاب.
Learner B4: أنا مفروض هنا يكون في كونديشنز صح؟
Learner B1: اللي هو لازم حد يجاوب يعني.
Learner B4: لا، لا، قصد كونديشنز لو اختار لا ال أوبشن التاني دا
Learner B4: يبقى لازم يجاوب على سؤال تحتيها.
Learner B1: يبقى ندم
Learner B4: يجاوب على حاجة تانية.
Learner B1: يعني حياتي.
Learner B4: يعني مثلا ساعات بيبقى إجابتك يسر نو لون نو بليز جوزتي فايمس.
Learner B1: أنا عملت. أهو.
Learner B4: ماشي.
Learner B1: لا حيوديه فين حيوديه فين ثانية.
Learner B4: لا لا 50.
Learner B1: أم
Learner B1: معلش اشرحيلي كانت سهلة كانت سهلة المطلوب بعد كده.
Learner B4: لو سهلة خلاص طب لو صعبة ليه كانت صعبة
Learner B4: لا يرد لا اعرف منين من انتم لا اعرف كيف اوصلهم؟
Learner B4: طيب.
Learner B1: أم.
Learner B4: إن.
Learner B1: ده موجود في مش هنا اصلا
Learner B4: ماشي خلاص.
Learner B1: هو بيبقى ممكن تقولي تحت تكتبي سؤال طب لو كانت صعبة كانت صعبة دي شايفها ممكن الإجابة.
Learner B4: تقف.
Learner B1: بأسرع حاجة في الكون.
Learner B4: طيب هنا توجيه الشغل المقصود بإيه.
Learner B1: أمين.
Learner B3: هسه إحنا ألريدي سألنا عن التاسسك طويل ولا لأ وكده مالوش لزمة بسرعة.
Learner B4: ما أنا شوية بسأل يعني إيه توزيع الشغل.
Learner B1: فكرة إن التذكرة بتكون كفكرة يعني فنيتك كانت الحاجة بتكون سهلة بينك وبين مهر ومفهومة ولا
Learner B4: السؤال ده مش واضح، لكن سألت السؤال.
Learner B1: شديد.
Learner B4: حيا الله.
Learner B1: هنرجع.
Learner B4: يلا ده تمام.
Learner B1: لا.
Learner B4: تمام.
Learner B1: ايش السؤال اللي إنت عايزين حقه.
Learner B4: أيوة قلي شلته؟ أنا عمال شلت إيه ام شلتي.
Learner B1: طب الكندر بقى.
Learner B4: أوكي آي ذي ون وات ديترو.
Learner B1: هل لقيت إنك.
Learner B4: أيوة هنا؟ أوكي.
Learner B1: مية.
Learner B4: دارفور.
Learner B3: في أي حاجة.
Learner B4: وأسئلة مكتوبة بخط عادي. أهو بس مش دي مشكلة
Learner B4: مع اللغة ازاي عملت مع لغة الإيج تمام في بقى تحت
Learner B4: مكتوب جملة غريبة جدا مكتوب إيه
Learner B4: جملة غريبة قوي ومكتوبة كذا مرة عشان يحرك بيتكم
Learner B4: الدعم يعني أدلة الدعم يعني ما فهمتهاش.
Learner B1: كنت أقصد بها اللي هو ال إي آي
Learner B1: بس ما كنتش عايز أقولو أوي.
Learner B4: طب إنت كنت ممكن تقول فوق إيجن إنت قلت فوق إيجن هل فتحت ايجاب.
Learner B1: عملية بحاول.
Learner B4: عشان هي أداة الدعم ليه أنا ما فهمتش يعني أديت الدعم يعني مش عارفة دي وجهة نظرنا بس ولا.
Learner B1: كمان.
Learner B3: حسن، خليني ستروكتور 1 كدا.
Learner B4: بالزبط وتحت وفد إيجن إن وإيه جنت وإجازتك.
Learner B1: أم
Learner B1: ماشي ماشي عادي تغيرت وحدة
Learner B1: تمام.
Learner B4: الوجبة غير مريحة.
Learner B1: تمام في كنشتي.
Learner B4: العفو أنا يعني.
Learner B1: فرنش.
Learner B4: أنا بالنسبة لي كده زي الفل أنا عسل جدا.
Learner B1: ممكن أقلك حاجة ممكن تفتحي الشي لستر بي هو هو الإبن الأخير
Learner B1: ما ادري مين عطول في عندك.
Learner B4: أوكي.
Learner B1: اهاه التابع فاين اللي هو تمام
Learner B1: دا كان كل سؤال مربوط بإيه.
Learner B4: حلو أوي هو ده بالضبط الفلتر. كنت بتكلم فيه مع ماري.
Learner B1: يعني دا لما كل سؤال مضبوط بيه.
Learner B4: ده إسمه عادي وده بالظبط أنا كنت عامله في الأسئلة بتاعت كل 1 أنا عايز أقيس منه
Learner B1: مظبوط.
Learner B3: طبيعي بس ما عنديش.
Learner B4: لا، قلت.
Learner B3: لا كنت أقول بس هو مش لكت أنا حسب صراحة إن هو ممكن عربي يبقى يعني مفهوم للجميع
Learner B3: بس هو لو كان بال إنجلش برضه مش كان يبقى سهل. نحن إكستراكت لو حابين نعمل داتا أو كده
Learner B3: بدل ما نترجم ولا.
Learner B1: نترجم إحنا قدامنا ما.
Learner B4: ، انت لسه هتقوليلي وأروح أدور بقى على الكلمة دي معناه.
Learner B1: تمام يا افندم.
Learner B3: أم بس فيدباك نزلوه أصلا كان بالإنكليش وكان نزيف.
Learner B1: عجبهم. مين قال لك إن هو عجبهم.
Learner B4: بقى قدرنا نعرف. هل الفيد باك ده
Learner B4: فعلا كان مفيد ولا الناس عندها كومنت عليه عايزين يحسنوك.
Learner B3: ما إحنا في الأسئلة إن شاء الله من ده يعني
Learner B3: خلاص ماشي أوكي تمام أنا تمام.
Learner B4: أنا بالنسبة لي كده الفورم زي الله بنا.
Learner B1: في حاجة الأسئلة اللي لازم يجاوب عليها مش كله
Learner B1: علشان ولا عامله كل ما عملتهاش أنا ما ظبطتش الرحلة دي و.
Learner B3: نحسب.
Learner B1: اختيارات.
Learner B4: وهو اللي عايز يقترح نشوف إن إحنا نسيبها أوبشنال ليهم.
Learner B1: طب معلش مثلا السؤال ده يختار 3 حاجات أخليه فعلا يختار 3 حاجات وإيه فهماني ولا لأ.
Learner B4: يعني ممكن تخلي الحاجات أنا فاهمة أفضل حاجات المندات تبقى مثلا الإسم والفريك
Learner B4: لكن الأسئلة أنا عايز أجاوب حاجة أنا عايز يجاوب حاجة يجاوب.
Learner B1: من.
Learner B3: لا، لا، بس أنا عندي رأي في الموضوع ده بس إن إحنا لما نيجي بعد كده في الآخر وحبينا نقول مثلا 10 اختاروا ده و5 اختاروا ده ما إحنا ممكن يكون العشرة ده إلزامي والخمسة ده ما كنش إلزامي إن إحنا نعرض نمبر صح لازم يكون نفس عدد الناس
Learner B3: عمل سيرفيه كلها عشان اللي حابب يعمل.
Learner B4: إنت لو حتعملي أنانز كده كده بتصنفلك اليس وإيه نو
Learner B4: بس خلينا نقول حاجة هو في اسئلة
Learner B4: يعني زميلتي قلت كده مريم في أسئلة مبنية على أسئلة.
Learner B3: ممكن الحاجات اللي هو تبقى أوبن كوستينز قوي نعملها مش كويس بس الأسئلة اللي محتاجين فيها نمبر لازم نقولها سبعطاشر 1
Learner B3: في.
Learner B4: فيها حالة من كنت اقول كل يبقى والجزء اللي تحت دول هم فايف اللي هي التاكس دي خلاها أوبشن.
Learner B3: إمم ممكن برضه.
Learner B1: كيف علي.
Learner B4: اللي تحت دي اللي تبقى أوبشن.
Learner B1: طب معلش إطلعي معي من الأول إطلعي معاي
Learner B1: سامعيه الو بالنسبة للمتخلف.
Learner B3: هذا.
Learner B1: النت عندها وحش.
Learner B3: طيب إنت عايز تعمل تاني.
Learner B1: الإسم مطلوب ولا.
Learner B3: مش انت قلت عايز نعمل مع انترفيو فخلاص نخليها مطلوب.
Learner B1: ماشي؟ والتراك مطلوب مستوى الخبرة مطلوب ولا لأ مطلوب.
Learner B3: إحنا قلنا الإمساك كله يبقى مطلوب.
Learner B1: ماشي أنا بعمله كله قهوة مطلوب.
Learner B4: كله مطلوب ما عدا آخر آخر حبة في.
Learner B1: طب معلش إعملي ثير كدا على أول حاجة عملتها.
Learner B4: يا مرحبا.
Learner B1: س.
Learner B1: انت فرحتك من اللي تحت.
Learner B4: والأخ عنده كله.
Learner B1: الأحمر ده أخليه يختار كم وحدة عمر الذي يخطر إيه.
Learner B4: ولا أي حاجة.
Learner B3: خليه براحته. أنا حاسس خليه كله براحته.
Learner B4: بالزبط بالذات. كل.
Learner B1: براحته ثانية واحدة خليكي معايا معلش أكتر حاجة دي برضه خليني مطلوب حدد عدد معين ولا لأ
Learner B1: دي أكتر حاجة خريطة قبل ما تبدأ.
Learner B4: ما فيش عمل معين.
Learner B1: من أثبتها كده يعني ما فيش عدد معين.
Learner B4: بالظبط عايز أجاوب على أي حاجة أجاوب راحته.
Learner B1: ماشي ابص على حاجة ماشي غالبا ما شي إمم.
Learner B4: عايزة مصالحة.
Learner B1: ميرسي ماشي.
Learner B4: طيب إحنا دلوقتي في في حاجة يا جماعة عشان
Learner B4: قوي إن إحنا نعمل فرم وإحنا عندنا حاجات كتير قوي مطلوب مننا نخلصها عبر يوم الخميس
Learner B4: يعني الفرن من هنا كبير جدا
Learner B4: واحنا لسا عندنا انتي بي وبروتوتيب وأنت طيب ونبص على اللبن برضه في 1,000,000 حاجة وحاجة
Learner B4: فهل حد شاف البروتوتيبل اللي حيعملها ازاي ولا إحنا لسه في الفرن.
Learner B1: والله.
Learner B3: أنا بس لي.
Learner B1: قولي قولي قولي.
Learner B3: ، لا كنت أقولها بس أكتر على
Learner B3: على لأن هو يبقى الفيداك أول حاجة أنت مبنية على أساس إيه.
Learner B4: طيب كلامك سليم بس هل إحنا عارفين أصلا إزاي نعمل بروتوتي
Learner B4: يعني أنا بس واقفة على إنفورميشن اللي بتجيلي
Learner B4: ولا احنا حراجع معاكم دلوقتي شربول لينك هاي فايف اي بروتشي.
Learner B3: أنا شفت التتويز ليبل أنا بس مشكلتي ن كريديت قليلة، قوي ف لسه أشوف أكثر حيكفي. ولا.
Learner B1: نجيب معاك هنجيب معاك لو صح نجيب معاك.
Learner B4: ولسه عايزين نعمل بي آر دي و عايزين نعمل فايف تو إيت يوزر بتاعتهم ونعمل شوت ووك ثرو
Learner B4: وبيج تيكنيكال إنتيغريشن.
Learner B3: طيب خلينا يعني خلاص يعني طب خلاص خلاص كده الفورم وان شاء الله.
Learner B4: من.
Learner B3: لا نبعتها.
Learner B3: وخلاص نروح بقى كل 1 يشوف حيبدأ إزاي يعني.
Learner B4: بالظبط إحنا نبعت الفرن خلاص زي الفل كدا
Learner B4: ونبدأ فينا نشتغل اللي عندك مريم ممكن ناخد مثلا في رأيك.
Learner B3: الرتو.
Learner B3: أنا حاسة. أنا حاسة إن أنا حبعتلهم عشان هم محتاجين يكتبوا يعني أنا حبعتلهم لينك ويدخلوا أسئلة كتير أوي في الموضوع مش حيكفي.
Learner B4: الأسئلة كانت بتقصدي.
Learner B3: بلس إن هو قال لي إن أنا أسأل أصلا حد ثاني فأنا مش عارفة هو أصلا يبقى عنده الأسئلة الإجابات لدي. ولا لأ فأنا هبعتهم الاتنين.
Learner B4: ماشي حابة تشتري معنا السينما كنت أتمنى برضه نبص عليها ولا.
Learner B3: أكيد ثانية.
Learner B4: عليها.
Learner B3: شكرا.
Learner B4: فيعني أي حد يعني لما خلص نبص عليها كده يجوع عليها ازاي.
Learner B1: أنا.
Learner B3: هو ده أنا.
Learner B1: كل حاجة جاهزة. أنا خلاص بعمل آخر يعني أنا.
Learner B3: إنت حتبعتيها للمنتجر ولا.
Learner B1: أوف. أنا.
Learner B4: أنا.
Learner B1: بس كده.
Learner B4: سؤال بس تقريبا نسيتو سألني نعمله.
Learner B1: آمين.
Learner B4: أم
Learner B4: خلينا أظبطهم.
Learner B1: ثانية وحدة ابص عليهم من أول ما عرفش في لايج ولا أنا اللي عندي كده تمام.
Learner B4: نفسك في الصبح.
Learner B1: متأكد من كلهم كلهم منورين تدخل قوي قوي قوي قوي قوي قوي قوي قوي قوي أيوه.
Learner B4: تمام.
Learner B1: قشط.
Learner B4: زي الفل خلاص نعمل هذا الوقت في الظروف.
Learner B1: تبعتيها لاسمو المهندس أحمد الأول.
Learner B4: ماشي هذا كله حلو.
Learner B1: أريد سيارة من عندك بقى.
Learner B4: يا الله طيب إحنا عندنا ديدلاين نفسنا بنرد على على الفورمي دي
Learner B4: الزبلانبي خلينا نقول بلاندي.
Learner B3: دائرة.
Learner B1: بصي إحنا عادي خالص نفس الأسبوع اللي فات إحنا ما مشيناش على فورم قوي الأسبوع اللي فات تمام
Learner B1: إحنا إيه في الأول هنري يعني حنكون جاهزين أنا أراه ثانيين دلوقتي بشوف أنا حبدأ أعمل
Learner B1: وتمام ده.
Learner B4: دي أهم حاجة.
Learner B1: إلى.
Learner B4: يا محل.
Learner B3: عايزين تبصوا كده سريعا أه.
Learner B4: انا بعتهالن لجواب.
Learner B1: آمين آمين.
Learner B3: خلاص أوكي إنتو جماعة أنا عاملة دلوقتي لو حابين تبثوا سريعا كدا على شكل الأسئلة
Learner B3: ولو حد عايز يزود اي اسئلة ممكن يبعتلي.
Learner B1: ما.
Learner B4: إنت إنت ممكن معنا نشوفه إنت على صح؟
Learner B4: أنا نوشن على نوشن ده.
Learner B3: على نوشن.
Learner B4: أوكي طيب ممكن تشيلي معانا عادي ممكن تديني بس فيو قولي هاف ديستر أوبشن ونص عليه يعني أوكي.
Learner B3: أنا ببعتهالكو دلوقتي.
Learner B4: خلينا نقراها كده على الروان ولو في اي حد عنده اي كومنتس هاي كومنت وإنت تشيك يعني للسؤال
Learner B4: وحطي.
Learner B3: أنا عملت كمان ألاو يعني عملت أدت انه اي حد ممكن يعدك فبس عادي أنا ممكن
Learner B3: بس اللي عايز يكتب كومنت يكتب مثلا وجنبيها إسمه أو كده أو يكتب عادي تحت مش لازم حتى تكتب إسمه يعني.
Learner B4: فرنش ويتش سوم أوف تو ميجور.
Learner B4: فرنش.
Learner B3: قصدي عالإنترنت بشكل عام يعني بالنسبة لهم لو عملوه فكده يعني.
Learner B4: ولا في ولا قصدك تي دي فوكسيديات.
Learner B3: كعامة هو بقى يشرحوا هم بالنسبة لهم حتى لو في فهم يكتبوا.
Learner B4: أوكي ماشي خليك لأن أنا لطف وما عندي. أي حاجة أضيفها على طول.
Learner B3: خلاص حابة إن إحنا نقسمها بكريتيريا معينة تبقى الموضوع واضح اكتر ممكن نعمل زي ما انت عملتي
Learner B3: الكتلة اللي انت عملتيها.
Learner B4: أوكي.
Learner B3: ممكن.
Learner B4: أوك.
Learner B3: بس غلبان الأسبوع ده أو نستخدمها
Learner B3: طب ممكن بقى الأسبوع الجاي؟ ولا حاجة.
Learner B4: غالبا. يبقى الاسبوع الجاي بس كويس إن إحنا مجهزين يعني ده أسئلتك عظيمة جدا الصراحة يشربوا.
Learner B3: ميرسي يعني برضه يعني هشوف تاني المقترحات لو حتى شفت او كدا يساعدني ممكن نسألها أكتر
Learner B3: شوية بس.
Learner B4: ريف.
Learner B1: بصي هو كده الصح اللي نعمله؟ نحنا نبدأ نشتغل على الطفل خلاص.
Learner B4: كبيرة جدا تصفي كبيرة وعنيفة فمحتاجين نجهزها.
Learner B3: ده كده كده يعني خلاص إن شاء الله.
Learner B4: خلاص بإذن الله بكرا حنتقابل عشان نشوف إحنا الكرة فين أشتغل على عالصف ويقولي واقف معاه
Learner B4: بحيث إن تقريبا بكرة اللص زي يعني قبل ما تسلمك يعني بقى إحنا يعني متأكدين إنه كلنا
Learner B4: على نفس المستوى والدنيا معنا تناول وفي احد ناقصه اي شيء نخلصها مع بعض.
Learner B1: والسنور.
Learner B3: خلاص.
Learner B1: ممكن. تكتبي بوست جميل ونبدا نشتغل عليه إزاي.
Learner B4: ما أنا حبدأ. أتكلم على موضوع ثاني موجودة لو في أي فيديوس أي حاجة عشان تقلقش غرام ولما.
Learner B3: معلش هو انتي تعمليلي الميندر على يعني على سيكل يعني.
Learner B4: عصير كل يوم.
Learner B3: طيب.
Learner B4: يعني عشان زميلنا حضروا بس يكونوا يعني.
Learner B3: ، أوكي فهمتك خلاص أوكي عادي.
Learner B4: تمام.
Learner B3: يلا قاطرك.
Learner B4: زي الفل نقول.
Learner B3: 4.